-Lea Thompson!
"Some Kind of Wonderful,"
weirdly enough,
that song not in the movie,
right?
-Yes! It was not in the movie
of "Some Kind of Wonderful."
-That's pretty interesting.
-Which is the weirdest thing.
I was like, "What?
You spent the money
for the title."
-Why is that song
not in the movie?
-Yes, my husband directed that.
-Well, yeah, I mean,
that's the --
that's the good thing
that came out of that.
-33 years.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's what I'm talking about.
Congrats.
-Hi, honey!
-Mwah! Mwah! We love you, honey!
Thank you for playing charades
with Ralph and Jennifer.
Have you met --
-I'm so sorry for your loss.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my -- geez.
-I mean, you are the home team.
-I was home team.
But, man, that got crazy.
Oh, my gosh.
Have you met those guys before,
Ralph or Jennifer?
-Well, Jennifer played
my daughter Zoey's mother
in "Before I Fall."
-That's right.
-And I remember seeing
"Flashdance" when I did
"All the Right Moves,"
with Tom Cruise.
That was a long time ago.
And I was a dancer.
I was like, "You can dance
and weld at the same time?"
-Yeah! Of course!
-Oh, my God!
-You can do whatever you want.
-Yes.
And, Ralph,
I auditioned for "Karate Kid,"
and I didn't get the part.
-Aww.
-I was bitter until now, but
since I beat him at Charades...
[ Laughter ]
I'm over it now.
-Can we talk about the
"Back to the Future" audition?
'Cause this is
a good story, too.
"Back to the Future,"
you auditioned for --
and spoiler alert.
-I got it!
-Yeah, you got it.
-I got the part.
-You pretty much know that,
yeah, you got it.
-But at the same time I was --
I got this part in
"A Chorus Line," the movie.
-Ooh.
-So I had to pick.
And it was
the girl who couldn't sing.
You know that part?
-Yes.
-"See, I really can't sing.
I really couldn't sing."
And then, so I had to decide
whether I wanted to say that
or, "Oh, my God.
It's Calvin Klein.
What a dream."
-Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
I mean...
Choices, choices.
-The choice was clear.
-The choice
was very, very clear.
-So I took "Back to the Future."
But the people
from "Chorus Line"
were very upset with me.
And they said, "Don't you want
to be a piece of history?"
[ Laughter ]
And I guess I am.
-Yeah, you are, actually!
Yeah, exactly.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Lea Thompson is a part of
history, pretty much.
Also, you know what's
another part of history?
Is that you were in the very
first Marvel movie.
You were in "Howard the Duck."
-Oh, yes.
-I mean, this is -- that's
the very first Marvel movie.
-Yes, I am
the first Marvel queen.
-Yes!
[ Laughter ]
-They kind of try to keep it
on the down low
over there at Marvel Studios.
-Yeah.
No, they kind of always
hint around sneaking
Howard the Duck somehow back.
I would love -- I think
we should bring it back.
I think we should do it.
-See, I want --
I want -- I've been in to pitch
a "Howard the Duck" movie
with Chip Zdarsky,
who did the comic book --
the last run of the
"Howard the Duck" comic book.
He put me on the cover.
And so we went in,
and we pitched it.
And --
-You've been directing
for the --
I mean, you're doing --
you're crushing it.
I know Zoey Deutch
is your daughter, who we love,
and she's been on the show
many times.
I love her.
-Yes.
Absolutely one of
our favorite guests.
And I always talk to her,
and she's like, "Oh, yeah,
my mom's directing this,
and then she's doing that."
And so I think
it would be perfect.
I think, Marvel, let's do this.
-Yeah.
-I've been directing
a lot of sci-fi shows,
big shows, to learn
how to do the special effects
and all of that.
I've been doing "Star Girl."
I have on one that was on
tonight and one next week.
And then,
I did "Resident Alien,"
which is a great show.
AND "Star Trek: Picard."
I took Sir Patrick Stewart
back in time.
Apparently, I am an expert
at time travel.
-Yeah, yeah, that's interesting.
Right?
Don't get typecast now.
-No, okay.
But, yah, I've been trying
to learn all my special effects
just in case Marvel calls.
-Yeah.
-You guys, yeah.
-You need some more
women directors.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Women.
-Did you always want to direct?
Being such a good actor...
I mean, do you go, like,
"Ooh, I think I could be
on the other side"?
-Well, I'm bossy,
so there's that.
[ Laughter ]
-That helps,
being a bossy director, yeah.
-And I've been directing
for like 17 years.
Yeah, I kind of did,
but when you have little kids,
it's so kind of
all-encompassing.
But I find --
I've done so many things.
I was a ballet dancer, singer,
I've been on Broadway.
[ Coarse voice ] And I get to
use my 43 years in show biz.
-Wow!
It's been forty --
-43 years.
-Let me tell you,
back in the day,
we didn't sit on couches.
We sat on the floor
and talked to each other.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Normal voice ]
You can use all that,
like you do on this show.
You're so amazing,
the way you sing and you dance
and you write and you create.
And it's so fun to be able
to create with people
something special
that makes them laugh.
-Yeah, that's what we try to do.
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-We have things
we have to talk about.
We have to talk about
"The Spencer Sisters" because --
-Oh, okay!
-Yeah.
This is where -- you just
came from here, from set.
-Yes, I just came from set.
I'm doing "The Spencer Sisters."
And this is the amazing
Stacy Farber,
and she plays my daughter.
I'm, like,
this fabulous mystery writer.
I get to be like, "Oh, my God."
I've got nails and everything.
And Spanx and extensions.
-Spanx.
[ Laughter ]
And we solve mysteries together.
She's an ex-cop.
-Fun.
-I'm in Winnipeg.
I got two jobs in Winnipeg.
One was with Stacy Farber,
and the other
is "The Disappearance
of Cari Farver."
What is going on with Winnipeg
and these names?!
-Wait. Stacy Farber
and Cari Farver?
-Yes.
-That's bizarre.
-I know.
How do I remember it?
-Yeah. Let's talk about "The
Disappearance of Cari Farver."
It's on Lifetime
this Saturday, 8:00 p.m.
What is the movie about?
How do we set it up?
-Well, it's just crazy.
You know,
If one thing we've learned,
people are cray, right?
-Mm-hmm.
-Last five years, there's
some cray things going on.
-People are cray. It's trending
on Twitter right now.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
The one thing we learned.
-So this is a real cray story.
It's kind of like
a love triangle.
A guy and two girls,
Cari and Liz.
And all of a sudden,
Cari disappears,
and she starts sending all these
horrible text messages,
and nobody knows where she is.
And I play her mother.
And of course,
I'm the one that keeps
going to the police and saying,
"Something is wrong."
-Yeah.
-There you go.
-That's it right there.
-That's it, in a nutshell.
-You have to do it.
Someone has to say it.
-Someone's mom --
-Someone has to say,
"Something is wrong here!"
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, there we go.
I auditioned for the part of
the mother. I did not get it.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Lea Thompson in
"The Disappearance
of Cari Farver."
Take a look.
-Look, I know
what you're thinking,
but she missed
her cousin's wedding.
She would never miss something
like that if she could help it.
And she's taking her father to
every single chemo treatment.
My daughter, Cari...
she is a wonderful person.
She really is.
But yesterday,
she didn't show up.
She didn't call,
she didn't text, nothing.
-Lea Thompson, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
"The Disappearance
of Cari Farver"
premieres this Saturday
at 8:00 p.m. on Lifetime.
We'll be right back with a
performance from Modern English!
Stick around!